SPEAKER 1: Throughout
this series,
a lot of what we've shown
you has been focused
on the BigQuery
console, but when
you have large amounts
of data or stakeholders,
manually running jobs
and creating resources
won't be very scalable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In today's video, we're going
to take a tour of the BigQuery
APIs so that you can get started
creating programmatic data
workflows.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The first API we'll discuss
is BigQuery V2, which
is really the core of BigQuery.
Here, you can manage data
warehousing resources
like data sets,
tables, and routines.
You can also manage machine
learning models as well
as execution resources or jobs.
Like most of the APIs
we'll discuss today,
you can interact
with the BigQuery API
through the various
client libraries
that we have available.
I'm personally a Python fan, so
having the Python library makes
it so much easier for
me to programmatically
interact with BigQuery.
OK, so when might you want
to actually use this API?
Well, first off, you may
want to programmatically get
answers to business
questions using data
that you have in BigQuery.
Let's say every week, you
want each sales team's revenue
to be added to a slide
deck so it can be presented
at your company's all hands.
Well, in a Google
App Script, you
can write some JavaScript that
loops through each of the team
names, and uses them as inputs
for a parameterized query that
sums up their total revenue.
We can use this information
to populate each team slide,
saving our analysts
lots of time copying
and pasting into the deck.
Alternatively, you might
want to use this API to add
some new data into your tables.
For example, maybe
you have information
about your customers stored in
your application's Cloud SQL
database.
You have your
customer addresses,
but you really want
to convert them
into lat/long
coordinates so you can
leverage BigQuery's awesome
geospatial capabilities.
Well, in this case, you can
create a Google Cloud function
that runs each night, and
grabs the new transactions
from the database using
an external query,
then uses the Google
Maps geocoding
API to grab customer
coordinates,
like I'm showing in
this Jupyter Notebook.
Finally, you'll create
and run a load job
that appends the new data
to your transactions table.
So cool.
And on the topic
of analyzing data
from transactional databases,
remember a few videos ago
when we talked
about connections,
which allow you to write
Federated queries against Cloud
SQL?
Well, there's an
API for that too.
The Connections API allows
you to programmatically create
and manage connections, which
can be really useful if you
have multiple databases
supporting your application,
like if you're a B2B
organization with one database
for each of your accounts.
Here, you may want to
write a program that
creates a new connection as
part of the customer onboarding
process.
This way, your BigQuery
users have access to the data
without needing to
send a request to you.
You could even weave in
the Google Cloud IAM API
to ensure that only
users who need access
to the specified account's
data are able to leverage
the connection.
Besides the BigQuery
and the connections API,
what else is out there?
Well, we talked a bit about
pushing new data into storage,
but BigQuery also has a
dedicated storage API.
The storage API
has two components.
The read client
exposes a data stream
suitable for reading
large volumes of data.
This includes features for
parallelizing reads, performing
partial projections,
filtering data,
and getting precise
control over snapshot time.
At Google, we use
the Snapchat API
to build out a series
of Hadoop connectors
that make it easy
to use BigQuery
as your source of
truth data lake.
You could also use it to build
out your own custom connector.
The Read Client,
currently in preview,
is the successor to
the streaming mechanism
found in the BigQuery V2 API.
It supports more
advanced write patterns,
such as exactly one semantics
for more robust streaming
inserts.
Keep an eye out for more
info on this coming soon.
Continuing on the topic of
ingesting data into BigQuery,
we also have the
data transfer API.
BigQuery Data Transfer Service
allows you to automate work
to ingest data
from known sources,
like Cloud Storage, Google
Marketing Platform, YouTube,
and lots of other third
party data sources
on a scheduled basis.
With the API, you can do things
like programmatically check
credentials, trigger a
manual run of the transfer,
or get the responses
from previous transfers.
Now we can't have a
discussion about BigQuery APIs
without mentioning the
Reservation API, which
allows you to
manage reservations
and assignments like we
discussed in one of our earlier
videos.
This is super useful for
programmatic workload
management.
Let's say the
dashboard for your CEO
needs to be run every
morning at 8:00 AM.
Well, you want it
to be super fast,
so you better make sure
the project it runs in
will have access
to enough slots.
With the Reservation
Python SDK, you
can write a program
that runs each morning
and creates a new
slot reservation
by specifying the reservation ID
and how many slots it contains.
Next, you'll assign the
reservation to the designated
bi_project where the
dashboard queries run,
and specify that this
assignment is for query jobs.
Finally, you can delete the
assignment and reservation
so that slots are released
back to the organization.
The last API I'll mention
is one of my favorites--
Data QnA, which is
currently in preview.
Are business users
at your organization
always pinging you to
query data on their behalf?
Well, with the QnA API, you can
convert natural language text
in queries into
SQL, meaning you can
build a super
powerful chatbot that
fulfills those query requests,
or even give your business
users access to
Connected Sheets so they
can ask analytics questions
directly in a spreadsheet.
Wow, that's a lot of different
APIs, all under the BigQuery
umbrella, and we
didn't even talk
through other related
products like Data Catalog.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But don't worry, we talked about
programmatic data governance
last week, so make
sure to check it out.
As always, thanks for joining
us for "BigQuery Spotlight,"
and make sure to look
through the links
below for details on
what we discussed today,
and code samples for
the various APIs.
And remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]